hey this is um this is really really
interesting because there's the viru
there's a viral video floating around
now of senator brian schatz
just eviscerating republican senator
josh hawley over his attempts to delay
joe biden's defense department nominees
and the video is great because of the
substance and because of the content but
the video is also great because it's a
reminder of the strategy that democrats
should be taking should be taking when
it comes to
fighting republicans and you know
remember when michelle obama said when
they go low we go high
and i've said many times before
we should not go down to their level of
lying
and the um uh uh just these corrosive
attacks on democracy in order to win
like we we shouldn't do that but when it
comes to rhetoric and style and tone and
strategy
we absolutely need to be doing some of
the things that the right does because
otherwise we're just going to keep
losing so let's get to this video clip
in this video clip you are going to hear
uh senator schatz
really just crush josh hawley who was by
the way one of the main pro-insurrection
senators let's listen and then we'll
discuss
he could have brought his floor charts
out here
and get given a withering speech about
what all of the things that he thought
went
wrong but he's doing a very specific
thing he is damaging the department of
defense we have senior dod leaders right
we have the armed services committee
coming to us and saying
i don't know what to tell him
i don't know how to satisfy him but he
is blocking the staffing of the senior
leadership at the department of defense
and this comes from a guy who raised his
fist
in solidarity with the insurrectionists
true and this comes from a guy who
before the russian invasion suggested
that maybe it would be wise for
zielinski
to make a few concessions about ukraine
and their willingness to join nato oh
boy this comes from a guy who just about
a month ago voted against ukraine aid
he's saying it's going too slow he voted
no
he voted no on ukraine aid and now he
has the call to say it's going too slow
and this final insult
is that until what secretary austin
resigns
that's not a serious request
people used to come to me during the
trump administration all the time do you
think trump should resign do you think
tillerson should that's a stupid of
course i think all the people i disagree
with should quit their jobs and be
replaced with people i love of course i
think they should all resign that's not
how this world works
that is not a
reasonable request from a united states
senator that until the secretary of
defense quits his job i'm going to block
all of his nominees that's preposterous
and coming from a person who exonerated
donald trump for extorting
zielinski for withholding lethal aid
they withheld lethal aid
until
unless zielinski would release false
smears against joe biden's son and then
he voted to exonerate president trump
for this and so spare me
the new solidarity with the ukrainians
and with the free world because this
man's record is exactly the opposite
who could say that a single word of that
is wrong
and of course brian schatz is right and
you know the stories you know the
ukraine story you know the josh hawley
insurrection story so this is less about
the facts
that rant which is not i mean listen
it's a sound bite but it's a two minute
and twenty second sound bite it's it's a
for our modern expectations that these
things need to be 20 seconds long to go
viral
it's two minutes and 20 seconds long
and it's more substantive and it's still
got over three million views it might
even be up to four at this point so
there is an appetite for this type of
attitude from the democratic party and
this is the attitude that the democratic
party needs to take
hone the anger
and keep calling out the worst of the
worst for their bs individually don't
speak generally speak individually josh
hawley does a bad act another
humiliating part but i'm not going to
vote to approve anybody confirm anybody
to dod
until trump's secretary of defense
resigns biden secretary of defense
refund give me a break that's absurd
you're a senator you're one of 100 you
understand how government works and it's
absurd that so many pretend that their
supposed concerns are genuine it's just
nonsense politically it's political
nonsense and so democrats
need to be making the statements and
i'm going to use the term performing and
i don't use that pejoratively
democrats are often right on substance
but they're not performing in the right
way and it doesn't get any attention
there is enough fodder from republicans
from what they are doing from their
hypocrisy and double standards and
absurdities for one of these viral
eviscerations of a republican basically
every day now you do it every day it
won't get as much attention but
certainly every week and part of the
issue is that democrats don't really
have a media outlet that approaches the
power of fox news i mean you've got a 24
7
propaganda agenda setting institution in
fox news and even if only a few million
people watch fox news at any one point
in time their agenda setting power is
significant and then you start seeing
the same talking points everywhere else
this is sort of what rush limbaugh
created where he it was the agenda
setting power and so democrats end up
trying to catch up and on defense and a
lot of people i know are going to say
but david what about msnbc msnbc is a
center-left corporate media network and
it is not the other side of the coin of
fox news it it's just not it's not even
close it's not what it is
and um it needs to be
said and repeated endlessly
unless the left starts doing more stuff
like this and this is just one you might
say but david this won't change anyone's
vote
this might change a few votes
but it's not going to be enough to
defeat josh hawley i don't even think
he's up for election maybe he is i don't
know if he's up this time around doesn't
matter but the point is this is the
attitude that needs to be present
everywhere as a minimum it won't even
guarantee victory
but
it's got to change it's got to change
because democrats are just not doing it
in the right way